there are people in washington dc that
are in elective office
and have been there for decades who have
mastered the art
of enriching themselves because
corruption goes to the heart
of our representative government
politics is the way to go because if you
get into politics through corruption
you can create some wealth for yourself
they will hold fundraisers for me they
will write campaign checks to me
they might even hire my son or my nephew
as a
lobbyist for them so it's not uncommon
to make five to ten million a year as a
lobbyist absolutely right look at the
people who have been in congress for 20
or 30 years
the founders didn't really intend this
how is corruption getting worse today
nancy pelosi has done this where she and
her husband
got access to ipo shares of stock and
these were companies
that had legislation sitting before her
in congress
i saw her network the other day 140
million dollars i don't know how she's
140 million dollars they
get to write their own rules and this
happens all the time
trump is probably not an ally to the
country club congressman and senate
would you agree with that
donald trump came in and he disrupted
that model
that's breaking all the rules if you
were to break down
the most corrupt families that we've
seen in politics
who would you put on that list probably
at the top of the list
would be the biden family
my guest today is the author of profiles
and corruption which has 4236 reviews on
amazon he's also the author of secret
empires
clinton cash that nearly cost i mean it
pretty much cost
hillary clinton the election in 2016
when he came out with that in 2015.
he's also got a couple of documentaries
that came out a recent one writing the
dragon which is a story of biden's
and hunter biden he's a former william j
casey research fellow at stanford
university
hoover institution similar to milton
friedman as well as thomas sol and many
other greats
so with that being said peter thank you
so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
great to be here i'm really looking
forward to it thanks so
so peter last time you wrote clinton
cash some people said that kind of
influenced and hurt the election this
time around
you wrote uh i believe it's profiles and
corruption which was the one that came
out this year january of 2020
and when we look at the numbers biden
won
76.3 versus trump 71.6
uh how come your book and videos
couldn't have more influence to turn
this thing around and
how come it wasn't as effective as
clinton cash i'm just curious and
obviously
your thoughts on the numbers of 76.3
versus trump 71.6
yeah boy talk about a little bit of
pressure there huh
um no i think uh look i think that uh
the people are concerned about
corruption
um it's not their only concern but it's
a major concern
um what i'm always hearted by is the
fact that uh
people are concerned about these issues
because corruption goes to the heart
of our representative government um a
corrupt official is not somebody who's
representing their constituents
it's somebody that's representing their
corrupt interests representing
themselves
so i'm just very glad that the books do
get the attention
i'm glad that uh at least uh some people
in the american public learn about
hunter biden and
the connections that the biden family
has to the chinese government
i certainly wish it had been more uh
because i feel like a lot of people the
mainstream media didn't want to go there
uh but what's exciting these days of
course is that there's all new sources
of information like this program
uh things online so it's very hard for
them to squelch a story like they might
have been able to do
five or ten years ago so i have a lot of
different topics i want to cover with
you you know you're somebody that's
every time you write a book people line
up to buy your books
people want to know what you have to say
new york time bestseller over and over
again
uh they're curious to know how your
process is issues your research all of
that combined together
so peter you know i i was born and
raised in iran so to to a family whose
mother's side communist that said
imperialist and
there was this joke my mom's family was
was from russia armenians assyrians
there's this joke about if you want to
be rich in
countries like that politics is the way
to go because if you get into politics
through corruption
you can create some wealth for yourself
how much of that applies to america
i think it increasingly applies to the
united states uh there's no question
about it i mean there's been similar
jokes in the united states uh
uh through our history uh in new jersey
there's an old saying you know
pass a bill uh create a living
you know in other words you you pass
some law you can create it and juice it
in such a way that you can self enrich
that's an inherent problem with
government but i think what's happened
in the united states
is you have a couple of phenomena that
are happening at the same time on the
one hand
uh you have a series of places around
the country where you basically have one
party rule
california would be an obvious example
whenever you have in a sense
one party rule where there's not really
a lot of competition between the parties
that invites in bread inbred corruption
but the second problem is more
foundational and fundamental
and that is that government is
increasingly
involved in so many parts of our lives
it creates more income
opportunities uh and that's i think a
mistake that people make is they got to
understand that
that part of the challenge we face uh uh
in
washington dc with the size and scope of
government is ideological there are
people who
actually defy the rules of history
uh to reply to define the examples of
history
and believe that socialism and
governments actually work so they're
actually true believers in socialism
but along with that you have a lot of
people in washington dc who are not
necessarily
committed ideologically but they know
that as government grows and expands
it creates business opportunities for
them
so if you look over the span of uh
american history of the last 70 to 80
years
the fact that the government's become
increasingly involved in healthcare
uh in energy uh in transportation
in technology in all of those areas that
creates a
business model opportunity for people in
washington dc
and politicians to self enrich uh it
allows them to extort money it allows
them to
create gateways or barriers to companies
that essentially
they have to pay politicians to get
removed um
so it is a problem that has existed in
our history
but it's getting worse it's getting
worse because of the lack of this
competition
in certain areas like california new
york but at the same time
because the government has expanded its
areas of responsibility
it creates a let's say target rich
environment
for corruption you're saying it's
getting worse wouldn't it be worse a
hundred years ago with no
phone social media it's tougher to break
the law and kind of make money on the
side you're saying it's getting worse
today
with more tools of being able to hold
people accountable where people are
texting
you're documenting more maybe 100 years
ago you couldn't document
how is corruption getting worse today i
think it's getting worse because of the
level of opportunity i mean if you were
a congressman
in 1900 let's say um the scope of what
the federal government did was actually
fairly limited
um you know this is before you had a
department of transportation the
department of energy department of
education
uh this was before you had a
regulatory regime uh that applied to so
many industries
um and the thing people have to
understand is that government
power creates a opportunity
uh for the benefit of the political
class there's actually a school of
economics called public choice theory
public choice theory really says you
have to look at government officials and
bureaucrats
the same way you look at a businessman a
businessman is trying to build his
business
uh for his benefit for the benefit of
profit that's actually good
that's what fuels our economy just
because somebody puts on a government
a hat does not mean that they're not
self-interested they're not
interested in their own uh a self-good
and their self-profit
um so we have to understand that's the
model so yes you are correct
there's more transparency today in the
sense that we have the internet
we have the freedom of information act
we have these tools
but the problem is the field of battle
for self-enrichment is so much
larger a congressman today has so many
more industries that he can effectively
shake down uh than a congressman in 19
1900 ever even could have dreamed of
can you unpack what shakedown means to
you yeah
shaketown basically means extortion
people are used to thinking of extortion
in the context of uh you know what the
mafia does
they you know they visit a local uh a
butcher shop
in buffalo new york and and they
basically say look if you want to
pay protection money it'd be terrible if
something happened to this shop
pay protection money and we'll make sure
that nothing happens well
that's extortion we all recognize that's
illegal we've seen that in movies
some people have experienced that uh
government
oftentimes can function the same way uh
there are many members of congress that
that use tools and techniques
that aren't widely discussed i've
written about them members of congress
have talked to me about them
uh they have something called a milker
bill uh a milker bill
it doesn't have anything to do with the
dairy industry uh it's designed to milk
money from certain industries so how
does a milker bill work
well if i'm the chairman of a powerful
committee in congress
and i need to raise money or let's say i
need to find a
a lobbying opportunity for my son
i'm going to introduce a bill in
congress to let's say
put a 20 surtax on the high-tech
industry in silicon valley now
i don't actually believe in this bill i
don't even necessarily want this bill to
pass
but what's going to happen is that when
i introduce that bill
i'm going to have a flood of lobbyists
from silicon valley come
and say congressman schweitzer why are
you introducing this bill
and what will happen over the next 60
days is a dance
whereby they will come and meet they
will hold fundraisers for me they will
write campaign checks to me
they might even hire my son or my nephew
as a lobbyist for them this happens all
the time
my question fundamentally is how is that
any different
than the shakedown of the shop owner in
buffalo new york
it's the same form of extortion it's the
same element that says
look something bad is going to happen to
you i'm going to take more money away
unless you pay me protection money now
and that happens in washington dc all
the time
and it's the kind of external behavior
um
that's become all too familiar in
washington i think that
there's sort of a myth a lot of people
feel that the problem in washington is
that there's all this money
flowing into washington that
corporations and businesses
around the world are just happy to send
their money to washington dc
they don't really want to but they feel
like they have to because if they don't
bad things are going to happen to them
and that's exactly
what the political class in washington
wants them to believe
because it's so lucrative for the
political class
so business model number one introduce a
bill that you have no interest in
to scare off whoever it is and any kind
of an industry
meat technology health care whatever it
may be
then wait for the lobbyists of those
companies to reach out to you
to say hey you know we don't think this
is a good bill can we change your mind
et cetera et cetera
then what happens because is it a way of
me paying
your campaign or is it is it site money
what happens next because that's the
question it's a great question
oftentimes it's campaign money
um uh actually in my book extortion uh
there's an example from uh
from uh congressman sorry from uh a
gentleman named mr
hofmeister who's the ceo of shell oil
and he described the meeting that he had
in 2009
remember 2009 oil prices pretty high
he sat before a congressional committee
members of congress including maxine
waters
essentially said we want to nationalize
your company
we think it's outrageous the profits
you're making hofmeister reported to me
and i put in my book
that after that meeting congressman
waters
talked to him and said i might
understand your
issue better if we spend some time
together and this was basically
saying you need to raise money for me
and i will take the threat for
nationalizing your business away
so what you're doing is you're having a
series of coded conversations but you
know
exactly what's going on a shakedown is
taking place
and the beauty or the genius of a milker
bill
is you don't actually want it to pass if
i introduce a bill
for a 20 tax on silicon valley and that
bill passes
guess what i can't introduce that bill
again and shake down silicon valley
i actually want the bill to fail um one
of the reasons that you see a lot of
tax credits uh that are passed for
example in 1981
congress passed a bill for an r d tax
credit
for companies to invest in research and
development
people wonder in in the business
committee why is that tax credit never
been made permanent
well the reason they ask that question
is they're not thinking
uh about this as a shakedown if they
make
the tax credit permanent um congressmen
can't go back to them and ask them for
money when they have to extend it
so they have these things called tax
extenders we're going to extend a tax
credit
for two to three years uh and then
what's going to happen is
they're going to have to come they're
going to meet with me they're going to
raise more money with me and then i'm
going to vote to extend it
for another couple of years but i'm
never going to make it permanent because
if i make it permanent
i lose my leverage in my ability to
extract money from
that's powerful by the way what you just
said right there so it's an increment so
let me
leave it to renew it you need to spend
money or else i'm not going to renew it
so you got to help me out
and it's constant it's not no it's never
ending so here here's the difference you
know i've interviewed a lot of the
mobsters out there whether it's
ammunitive garbano colada
frenzies a lot of them have sat down
with them and the attorneys oscar
goodman who's the legendary attorney for
spelatra and a lot of the mobsters the
difference between
what happens to politicians and mobsters
is
every one of them did time okay
the part where voters both on the left
right in the middle
are losing trust in the system is
because
when's the last time a big politician
did time
and so the audience kind of sits around
and says i guess they didn't do any
anything corrupt because i don't see
them doing any kind of time so when is
the last time we had the highest level
of politician that did time
for doing extortion or corruption or
anything that you're talking about
it's been a very long time and and uh
you know part of the problem is
that they get to write their own rules
now you know
corporate executives don't get to write
their own laws uh school teachers don't
get to write their own laws i don't get
to write
my own laws you don't but members of
congress do
and so they know where those lines are
and they are
able to engage in behaviors that if the
rest of us were to do
they would be considered extortive
practices so for example
um if a corporate executive tried to
leverage their position for their own
personal
benefit in other words they were the
head of let's say general electric
uh and as part of their official duty as
ceo
they tried to leverage taking an action
or not taking an action
so they could derive a personal benefit
uh they would at a minimum be in trouble
with the sec
and probably be in trouble uh with
federal prosecutors as well
because that's against the law that
happens in congress all the time
why because congress has written the
rules in such a way
to where they do not apply to their
behavior uh one of my earliest books uh
that i wrote about corruption
involved insider trading on the stock
market by members of congress
um and a lot of people were outraged to
learn this
that if a corporate executive trades
their own company's stock
with what's called material non-public
information in other words they know
something that nobody else knows as a
function of working for that company
so they trade on it and profit they're
going to go to jail and lots of people
have done that from
secretaries to corporate ceos that law
does not apply to members of congress
so if you're the chairman of the senate
armed services committee for example
uh and you are you know for a fact that
a
certain defense bill that's highly
contested is going to pass
and it's going to mean huge sums of
money for boeing
or huge sums of money for another
defense contractor
you are as a senator allowed to buy and
sell
stock in that company i would argue
that's non-public material information
that's going to affect the stock price
and yet for years members of congress
were exempt from that law
it was only when we called it out i i
did a book that became a bestseller
we did a segment on 60 minutes uh that
caused a big up for
did they pass the bill called the stock
act she technically declare that it's
illegal for members of congress to
engage inside of trading on the stock
market
the problem is they later went back and
watered down that bill so that bill
really does not have much meaning
anymore but my point is to
to answer your question is the reason
very few
powerful political figures go to prison
is because they get to write their own
rules and they know where the lines are
and the lines are very different for
them they're much more narrow for us
than they are for them that's why you
don't see a lot of people going to jail
in positions of power how does that make
sense though so if that's the case
and if i'm a voter whatever side i'm at
you know each side thinks the other side
is corrupt liberals think republicans
are corrupt conservatives think the
democrats are corrupt both sides
are are talking about the other side is
corrupt but no one's seeing anyone
getting trouble
why should i trust anything anyone's
talking about and you know why should i
sit there and say
well i trust in the law to know that
that person is doing wrong
so and then what is the price and
potential future consequences
if the voters don't believe in
you getting in trouble for doing corrupt
behavior so
then i don't trust in the politicians
and how do we address that i mean
that's a big concern because you're
hearing it on both sides
everybody's talking about how the other
side is corrupt who do you believe and
what methods should be taken for these
guys to be held accountable
uh i think it's a great question i think
what we're seeing in the country today
the political tumults on the left right
and center is precisely to your point
uh the fact that there is distrust i
don't think there's distrust in the
system
as much as there's a distrust in the
leadership and how they have manipulated
the system
i think a lot of people recognize that
that you know the founding
fathers gave us this this powerful
system that diffused power
uh that made sure that power would not
be concentrated they
like that system the problem is that
that there is in a sense
a consensus in washington dc a lot of
people don't realize that
there's a consensus in washington dc on
these corruption issues what do i mean
uh what i'm saying is that
bipartisanship is not dead in washington
most people on the on the right and on
the left
that are in positions of authority in
washington dc
generally agree to the ground rules
of of how what i call legal graft occurs
in washington
they accept the fact that members of
congress
have family members that are lobbyists
even if they're not qualified and that
those family members get paid
uh because of the position of authority
that their mother or father might have
as a member of congress
um they all know it's corrupt but the
ground rules are such that they all
are benefiting so there's a consensus
that's emerged they don't talk about it
so what you have is you have of course
red states and blue states in america
what we also have is really the rest of
america
against the washington beltway um and
that i think is underappreciated and i
think one of the reasons that you see
a right left divide is because there are
leaders in washington who don't want
there to be a consensus on this issue
i find lots of times whether i go on fox
news or whether i go on wisconsin public
radio
which is left of center by and large
they grouse and they're concerned about
the same thing about corrupt leadership
they might be pointed at finger in a
different direction
but they're talking about corrupt
leadership and what we need to have is a
consensus
uh number one term limits i know it's
been discussed many times but if you
look at
the corrupt behavior that involves
elected officials in washington dc
it's almost to a person the longer they
stay in power
the more they become seduced by power
the more prone they are to engage in
corrupt behavior so
if you've been in congress for 30 years
the odds are infinitesimally higher
that you're going to engage in corrupt
or extorted behavior than if you've been
there for three years
term limits would be a great way uh to
start
second of all a ban on lobbying by
members of congress
and their immediate family members uh
this is a
a position that has been supported by
everyone from aoc
on the left to ted cruz on the right
there's another consensus point that i
think would be enormously helpful
because
you would get away from this
self-enrichment model
where elected politicians feel that they
are entitled
they're doing great service to the
country they're irreplaceable but
they're not paid enough they're not
appreciated enough so it's okay to
engage in this sort of legal graft
where their son or daughter suddenly
becomes a highly paid lobbyist
even though they have absolutely no
expertise there are areas of consensus
the problem is the left right divide
prevents us
i think from going forward and
addressing some of these issues
that's that's powerful the term limits
and the ban on lobbying members of
congress as well as family both aoc and
ted cruz agree on that
so who doesn't want those two
to pass both term limits and ban on
lobbying who are the people both on the
left and the right said no no no we're
not good we're not we don't want to pass
that
well i think a lot of them i think if
you if you
if you had a open uh uh
discussion um uh where they were candid
most elected officials would be opposed
to those pieces of legislation the
problem that they have
is that both of those are supported by
of their constituents so the point is
they don't want to have a debate in this
discussion about it when the issue of
insider trading
by members of congress came up a bill on
that matter had been introduced years
before
and they had had maybe 15 sponsors once
it became public
once it reached critical mass once the
american public
left right and center became outraged
and it became an issue
you suddenly went from having 15
sponsors to more than
300 in the house of representatives why
did they do that
they did it because they felt they
needed to do it or they were going to
offend enough constituents whereby they
wouldn't be reelected
so the issue here on term limits and the
ban on
on uh uh lobbying the real critical
issue is therefore
for there to be a consensus enough to
where elected officials
fear uh that issue and feel like they
have to vote for it or they're gonna
lose their jobs
otherwise it's very difficult to get
most
members of congress to do something
that's going to end up
affecting their ability to enrich
themselves and their family
peter can you give some names of who's
against it and who's for it you just
gave two names aoc and ted cruz
that would be four banning lobbying uh
but who's
against you know let's keep terminators
let's keep lobbying the waiters can you
give us an idea which camp is which camp
well i would look at the uh at the
leadership of the house of
representatives whether it's nancy
pelosi or steny hoyer
both of them have been in congress for
decades uh have never been in favor of
term limits
um uh their view which i think is wrong
is that somebody's been in congress has
a certain uh amount of expertise
uh that's needed um i don't think that's
true at all
um i think there are many qualified
people that can come in and take their
positions
i think if you look at the us senate you
have the same thing i mean there's
a reason uh senator mitch mcconnell has
not brought a term limits to
uh to the floor uh and does not want to
have it discussed
so again look at the people who have
been in congress for 20 or 30 years
they become accustomed to it and the
founders didn't really intend this
uh initially to be in the senate and to
be in the house of representatives
the first hundred years of american
history was kind of seen as a bird
it was kind of seen as something you did
as an obligation
to your community your state and to your
country
uh you're somebody who had success in
farming or as a printer or as a
you know raising horses whatever it was
you ran for office you served for one or
two terms and you went back to what you
did before
uh really beginning in the 20th century
this idea of a career politician
where you could do good and do well
where you could enrich yourself by
congress that is a relatively new
phenomenon in the united states
and a very very dangerous one so
i would look at you know probably 75
of both political parties in washington
dc
and elected office would not want those
bills to pass
but i would also say that the vast
majority of them would vote for it
if they believed that their constituents
were fed up and wanted those pieces of
legislation to pass
so so if that's the case if what you're
saying is
75 of them would hate to have term
limits and ban on lobbying
if that's the case wouldn't it make
sense that many
current republicans whether they're in
the senate or the house
probably are not fans of a guy like
trump because trump could cost them
their job and their ability to lobby
because that's how they've been able to
get uh
constantly reelected over the years so a
trump is probably
not an ally to the country club
type of people of you know uh
congressman and senate would you agree
with that
oh absolutely i mean look uh no donald
trump
is uh to use the term that they use in
silicon valley in the tech space don't
disrupt her
uh he has fundamentally changed
in a lot of respects not at all but in a
lot of respects
the business model of washington dc of
how things are done
how are things done in washington dc you
serve in the cabinet you serve in
congress you leave you become a lobbyist
or you go into
government relations which is really
just another form of lobbying
or you end up going to work for a
government contractor that you as a
member of congress
earmark legislation to get them extra
money
that's the way business has been done in
washington dc for a long time
uh and like trump or not like the tweets
or not donald trump came
in and he disrupted that model he
started talking about it
he started airing it he pushed for
reforms
uh here was a guy who himself did not
come up through the political system
in fact he complained uh and rightfully
so
about having to write checks for
politicians because
he was a real estate developer and he
needed to make sure he had access to
people
who might be disruptive to what he was
trying to do um
that's breaking all the rules you're not
supposed to talk about these things
publicly
you're not supposed to call people out
on them uh you're supposed to
allow the system to function the way
that it has for decades
on a bipartisan basis whether clinton or
bush or obama has been in office
that's basically the way that business
has been done trump came
in and and aggressively worked to change
that he has success in some areas
in other you know other areas less so
because again he needed the cooperation
of congress and that never happened
so trump has been a disruptive force
those that like his policies are not
those that like
his personality or not cannot ignore or
i think diminish the fact
that he has undermined this business
model in washington dc and that in my
mind
is unequivocally a good thing i i've
spoken to many of my friends who were
former lobbyists
and they shared with me the kind of
money that's potentially there to make
but
maybe for the viewer that hasn't had the
ability to talk to somebody to know what
kind of
money lobbyists make what is the
business model for the lobbyists not
not the you know politician but the
actual lobbyists representing a company
what is their business model
uh well their business model is to take
their position
and their position may have been as a
congressional staffer it may have been
for a member of congress
and then when they leave office whether
they retire from congress or they
leave as a congressional staff or
they're voted out of office as a member
of congress
it's to become a lobbyist and to go to
the very people
uh that you perform services for while
you were in office
and to now get paid um so you know
think about it that think about it this
way sometimes there are transactions
where if i'm purchasing something from
you
you give me a good and i pay you back
directly
sometimes if we're exchanging a service
you perform a service
and we sign a retainer agreement i don't
pay you the full amount but i pay you a
certain amount every month
just to make sure that we have that
retainer agreement lobbying is very
similar
oftentimes they use the retainer model
so if i'm the powerful men
you know powerful chairman of a
congressional committee i decide to
retire me i become a lobbyist let's say
i was chairman of the house budget
committee
enormous power influence on federal
government spending
i'm going to set up a lobbyist shop and
what's going to happen is
all the government contractors all the
individuals who are getting government
money
are now going to hire me uh as a
lobbyist
and i can make 50 000 a month just from
one client
and i might have 15 or 20 clients at the
same time
basically what i'm going to use is my
position as the former chairman of the
committee
to do what i'm going to go to the
current occupants
and i'm going to say look i need you to
do me a favor i have this client that
needs this written
into legislation or they need this this
favor done
and the current occupant based on the
way it works in washington dc
is going to play ball why are they going
to play ball because when they leave as
chairman
of the house budget committee they're
probably going to do the same thing
so it's a business model in a system
that is on rotation
um and it's very you know infrequently
talked about
uh it's very infrequently discussed why
because both
sides do it um it's it's one of the few
things in washington that's still
bipartisan
but this ability to make money as a
member of congress
when you really don't necessarily even
have any other skill set
other than the fact that you know other
people in positions of power
is an enormously alluring way to make
money
and nobody wants to disrupt that so it's
not uncommon to make five to ten million
a year as a lobbyist if you're a good
lobby oh yeah that's
absolutely right um and also you know to
be clear
there's a lot that you can do in the
area of let's say government relations
um that's not technically lobbying but
but it's essentially the same thing with
a few slight modifications so
you take a guy uh like senator tom
daschle
a former a leader for democrats in the
u.s senate he's been out for
uh uh for a while uh but tom daschler
will say
i'm not a lobbyist i'm in government
relations but what does he do he
represents pharmaceutical companies and
others
that have a beef or that have a problem
or want a favor
from the federal government and as long
as he doesn't cross that threshold
into being a lobbyist whereby he diverts
a certain amount of his time
to asking for specific legislation to
pass
he can avoid being labeled the lobbies
but he's still pulling in 50 000
a month from a client doing favors and
getting benefits from washington d.c
i mean that's real money making five to
ten million a year you got you got
pretty good
lifestyle now why do some of these guys
like if nancy wanted to leave and
say i don't want to do what i'm doing
anymore i'm going to go out there and be
a lobbyist and open up my own place and
make a bunch of money why why is she
staying in why is schumer staying in
because the money isn't that good i mean
i saw her net worth the other day 140
million dollars i don't know how she's
140 million dollars
and i saw that 60 minutes by the way but
why aren't some of them
leaving to make more money as a lobbyist
that's a good question i mean some
people i guess have you know different
different motivations but i think to be
more to the point
there are people in washington dc that
are in elective office
and have been there for decades who have
mastered the art
of enriching themselves what i would
call again legal grafts
but they use their position as a member
of congress to self-enrich themselves
and let me just give you a couple of
examples one would be uh issues relating
to
stock market manipulation and favor and
this would be an example with nancy
pelosi
so let's say you are a senator from the
great state of texas
and i want a favor if i walk in and i
give you a shoe box
with a hundred thousand dollars in cash
um
we're going to be in trouble because
that's illegal i can't pay you a bribe
you can't accept a bribe and insurance
in exchange for a favor
but consider this and this is something
naturally pelosi has done for decades
but consider this
i need a favor from you senator um and
oh by the way i'm connected with this
company
that's going to be going public um and
and i can get you
access to the friends and family round
of ipo
stock whereby you can buy stock for
pennies on the dollar
and when this stock goes public you're
gonna make a hundred thousand dollars in
a single day
now if that's our conversation
that's actually not illegal uh and nancy
pelosi has done this i mean we found uh
in our investigation with 60 minutes uh
at at least
eight instances where she and her
husband got access to ipo shares of
stock
before companies went public and these
were companies
that had legislation sitting before her
in congress
uh the most extreme example was visa the
credit card company
that went public in 2008 um
she and her husband got 5 000 uh
of pre ipo shares of stock in that
company
visa had legislation they wanted killed
she killed that legislation
when visa went public pelosi and her
husband made a hundred thousand dollars
in a single day
um so that's one example of how this
works so
you don't have to leave office
necessarily to cash in
if you're smart and clever and willing
to frankly be corrupt
there are things that you can do in
office let me give you another example
of how it works
and that would be what i would call the
land deal uh and here
i can cite examples of harry reid the
former senator from nevada
i can also talk about dennis hastert the
former republican speaker of the house
in denver dennis hastert's case um
his net worth when he became speaker of
the house
was minimal it was a couple hundred
thousand dollars by the time he left
only eight years later he was worth
millions of dollars
now how does that happen he's a former
wrestling coach
went into congress how did that happen
well he used what i call the land deal
so he's the speaker of the house he buys
himself individually as a private
citizen as he can
a a parcel of land in the middle of
nowhere in illinois where he's from
i mean this is rural illinois in the
middle of nowhere gets the land very
cheap
within 18 months he is the speaker of
the house
uh introduces the highway transportation
bill
for federal subsidies to transportation
in that bill
includes legislation for something
called the prairie parkway
which is going to run where through
illinois which is going to run where
right by the property that he had
purchased a year and a half
earlier the valuation of that land went
up
dramatically he made literally half a
million
dollars just in that one deal and here's
the scary part
what he did was exposed it's not illegal
it's not illegal to do what he did so
there are many things
that elected officials in office can do
right now
to self-enrich themselves that's why
nancy pelosi is now worth more than a
hundred million dollars
uh having been in congress for the last
30 years her husband's a businessman
a lot of his business deals dovetailed
very nicely
with the legislation that she's working
on in washington
how much of politics is it about
you know the industry of politics
attracts corrupt people
or the industry of politics corrupts
people
uh i think it's both and i don't say
that a cop
out but i think it's both i mean i think
there are people that that
uh come in there idealistically uh and
and get seduced
um one of the people that i've gotten to
know over the years is
the former governor of louisiana former
congressman bobby jindal
um and bobby jindal uh told me one time
when he served in congress i believe he
served three terms
um he said when i first got there you
know
they talked about fundraising and all
these things we were gonna do and he
just said
he said it just seems so dirty it just
seems so dirty you know
you're supposed to pick a committee uh
that that's gonna allow you to raise a
lot of money you're not going to
raise a lot of money sitting on the
veterans committee you want to be the
financial services committee
because you can really shake down those
wall street guys he said when you first
get there you hear that
it just feels so dirty and awful he said
but after that you're there a couple of
years you're like
yeah that's how things are done uh he
said it's it's
like when you first get there it's
successful but after a couple years that
festival becomes a hot tub
so there's no question there are people
that go there with good intentions
they get caught up with the power they
get seduced by the power
and they are corrupted but let's also be
clear there are people who go in there
and their intention i think pretty early
on they see the extractive power of
being a member of congress
let's be honest they don't really have
life skills they're going to lend
themselves to
rising in the corporate world or in the
medical field or in the law profession
they're not capable of running their own
businesses but they are
capable of shaking down a people and
abusing their power so politics attracts
those people as well
regardless whether they come in with
good intentions or they come in with
corruption
my point would be term limits stops both
of them
top stops people in both of those
categories
from staying for a long period of time
and exploding their position
interesting that's uh that's a good
perspective on both ends that how it
takes place so
you've written books clinton cash secret
empires profiles and corruption
and you've been studying this topic for
quite some time you started writing
about i think you wrote a book about
reagan back in 03 i think
i think it was when you were you've
written prior to that
as well um if you were to break down
the most corrupt families that we've
seen in politics
both sides over the last i don't know 40
50 60 years
who would you put on that list great
question
um i would say uh that um
probably at the top of the list in terms
of breadth and scope
uh would be the biden family um and i
don't say that
clinton yes i would say i would say the
biden family
um and the reason i would say that is
the size and the scope
in the case of bill and hillary clinton
um
they ran a very successful uh
corruption racket um you know whether
it's legal or not is obviously open to
debate
uh but it essentially involved the two
of them and they were tag teams so
bill clinton is president of the united
states his wife is first lady
he leaves she becomes a senator he's a
private citizen
but it essentially becomes if you want
to benefit uh
if you want some benefit from senator
hillary clinton pay bill clinton
and benefits will flow your way when she
becomes secretary of state
you pay bill clinton inflated speaking
fees you give them other other benefits
um and at the end of the day um uh you
know the clintons enriched themselves
the clinton foundation was corrupt the
speaking fees were corrupt
no question about it but what you have
with the bodies
is really unique um in in terms of the
scope and the breath what do i mean
in terms of breath um people know about
hunter biden a lot of people do they've
heard about hunter biden
they may have even heard of james biden
uh but as i point out in my book there
are actually
five members of the biden family i call
them the biden five
who i argue engaged in corrupt behavior
some of it legal some of it probably
questionable
but the point is five members of the
family have enriched themselves
um and they've been very blatant about
it um if you look at hunter biden's
career
um even when his father was a senator uh
he was a lobbyist working for delaware
entities
looking for federal grants well where
would delaware entities
go to look for federal grants they
debate 100
father they hire hunter biden to do that
job
he's a lobbyist in other respects um
when it and when it becomes clear
that you have to disclose uh the fact
that you're introducing earmarked
legislation
for the benefit of a family member who's
a lobbyist
hunter body is forced to switch
positions and do something else
uh when his father becomes vice
president of the united states
he because he becomes involved in
corruption on a global scale
and this is where i talk about the
breadth and the depth and what i mean
here is the depth of corruption
the corruption involving the biden
family it's not akin to
a you know a nephew of a congressman
who's trying to get a rotating contract
um uh you know so he can make an extra
buck
the corruption we're talking about with
the bodies involves foreign governments
it involves foreign governments
specifically the chinese government
which is our chief rival on the global
stage
it involves corrupt oligarchs in ukraine
so that is hard to beat
as as far as i'm concerned um so i would
put the bindings at the top of the list
i would probably put the club the uh the
the clintons uh
seconds um there is uh there was a
republican senator um who has had three
members of his family who has been
lobbyists
um i would put them near the top list
the name is escaping me right now he's
still in office
uh a senator from uh from missouri um i
don't know why the name is escaping me i
would put him on the list i read about
him in my book on uh on extortion
um he would be number three on the list
um and then i would probably put
mitch mcconnell and elaine chow on that
list as well
uh for their ties to uh the the
government of china
uh in their case it's not quite as bad i
think as the bidens
uh because in her case her family
actually did have a shipping company uh
before she married mitch mcconnell
before he
uh arose in power as a us senator uh but
there's no question
that they have benefited from the
largesse of the chinese government
and that is as a result of the fact that
he has softened his position on china
over the years
as elaine chao has as well
you see you know when you're saying that
to me um
we saw a lot of stuff about bill clinton
and the clintons being
corrupt and all the articles came
afterwards well look at what happened
with them in africa and they went in
but they were doing corrupt with the
leaders of africa and then haiti when
the big earthquake happened they went
out there saying we're going to build 5
000 homes at
i don't know 59 million dollars ended up
building 2600 homes at 90 million
dollars and where did that money go to
and
they paid bill clinton 350 two times to
give it speech
where typically he was making 150 to 200
at the time okay
i saw all of that that's fine but to me
that's
after he left being a president after he
left being a president
and for the most part maybe america
doesn't want to humiliate a former
president
maybe it's not good for america so we
pardon and just kind of leave it alone
even when you know trump said because
you'd be in jail he didn't come out when
he had the house senate and
presidency he didn't go after hillary so
maybe he was somebody behind closers
whispered and said
trump you may want to not do hillary
because eight years from now someone's
going to come after you maybe just kind
of
slow your role maybe there is that
exchange let's not humiliate
the bigger leaders but uh biden was not
a president he ran
with all of this stuff and you're seeing
the data so
light and sun was paid 5 million from a
chinese oil company cefc you know he
created a one billion dollar fund bhr
from the state-owned bank of china
and owned by state bank of china
received three and a half million dollar
wire transfer for
elena baturina the wife of former mayor
of moscow earn 4.2 million
from ukraine energy company barisma okay
if all of that stuff is true
if all of that stuff is true how the
hell did
biden get 76.3 million votes
if it's as corrupt as some people say it
is because
i'm not worried about the 42 percent of
democrats
that could care less what happens as
long as trump is out
they're happy and i don't care about the
not that i don't care i don't
put the weight behind the 44 percent of
republicans that just go right
all the way down as long as it's not the
left they're happy and put the other
four percent aside of libertarians green
whatever you want to call it
i look at the 10 percent the 10 is who
rules the world the 10
is who rules our elections right the 10
is sitting there saying
peter you know that documentary you did
that was live on the blaze tv and
you know saying that biden did this and
biting it down biting this we bought the
clinton cash so hillary didn't get
elected
but i don't know i'm seeing it on this
channel i'm seeing it on all these
people that are talking about biden
if it is really so true about hunter
biden how did joe biden become the
president-elect
it's a great question i mean it's it's
it's mystifying to me as well i mean i
live and breathe
the research that we do on corruption
and cronyism so
i take these issues very passionately i
think part of the problem
is that um a large portion of the
american people are not that familiar
with the story of biden corruption and
the reason is that it got very
little attention from the mainstream
media
abc news did a story on it uh uh in late
2019 that i thought was pretty good
uh that was mentioned in the new york
post uh there are obviously several
stories there
uh the wall street journal did a story
but the major networks
uh the new york times the washington
post really did not
demonstrate much curiosity at all about
this story and that to me is really
shocking because
one of the oldest stories in journalism
is follow the money
i mean think about all the times that
that
we've turned onto our tv and we've seen
the story about
you know uh big oil or big tech or big
labor unions
that uh you know uh held fundraisers for
an elected official
and that elected official then sponsored
legislation to benefit those entities
that's a hallmark of joseph i used to do
those stories with cnn
um this is that story on steroids
because you not only have money in the
equation
you have a foreign government in the
equation you have corrupt foreign
oligarchs in the equation
you have the fact that hunter biden has
no skills to sell i mean the question i
keep asking my friends they say oh you
know well
hunter biden he's a businessman he has
to make a living
you know my question is what was he
selling
what was he selling he doesn't have a
skill set he has nothing to offer the
chinese government
other than his connections to his father
that's why he's being given five million
dollars
um so i think the first part of the
problem is
that a lot of the media ignored this and
suppressed this story
you saw what happened when the new york
post tweeted about it
twitter shut down their twitter accounts
i mean this was
blatant censorship and these are
precisely the kinds of stories that
people should know about
um nobody has challenged the facts about
this nobody has said that it's not true
nobody said hunter didn't get involved
in this private equity fund or get this
money from the chinese energy company
or get the million dollars a year from
barisma they just simply have said
end of story nothing to discuss so the
first problem has been
immediate censorship i think the second
issue is that
we are a very divided country and uh
there there are
a large portion of the country that
believe
that they should turn a blind eye to the
corruption on their side
in order to make sure that their side
wins
and my argument i guess to them would be
whether you're a republican whether you
are democrat
no political figure is irreplaceable um
what democrats should have done because
this issue with corruption and biden's
not going away
he's a president-elect he's probably
going to be president of the united
states
the issue of this corruption is not
going away this issue should have been
aired in the primaries
this issue should have come out in the
primaries it should have been had
aired and people have decided at that
point we're happy with this
then so be it but now we have a
president
that's elected um and people have
decided to turn a blind eye
and this never ends up well when you
have elected officials that are corrupt
uh they end up making poor decisions
they end up being distracted
they may end up even having some legal
liability and my point is
nobody's irreplaceable um what
politicians will tell you
is look aside ignore this corruption
you need me to advance the cause to
fight the cause to get this work
done nobody is irreplaceable for every
joe biden for
up every corrupt member of congress you
can find
people that you agree with on your side
that can run for office
and get that can be effective that are
not corrupt at that time and that's what
i tell everybody left right and center
do not turn a blind eye to corruption uh
from somebody on your side
that's what they want us to do and
that's why we were
where we have a situation with so many
uh elected corrupt officials
well the current business model doesn't
incentivize to do that
the current business model in the voting
system that we have
it doesn't incentivize me to say oh yeah
some guy on my side is being corrupt
it doesn't do that there's no incentive
we're not teaching that
the conf structure if you want to say
isn't set up in a way for somebody to
say
yeah you know what i disagree with
there's you know because if if i recall
in the democratic primary when they were
debating all the candidates
whoever you had on the stage the sanders
the warren
you know pete all of these guys were
debating i don't remember hunter biden
coming up at all
i don't remember anything about the
family coming up so do you think behind
closed doors
the dnc tom perez is sitting down saying
guys
no the one thing you can do if you even
think about bringing anything about the
biden family
that's a no-no we're going to do this
does it go that deep
or am i you know is that too much of
thinking to say the dnc doesn't go that
deep
uh you know it could be i mean look
there's no question you're exactly right
this issue did not really come up in the
primaries hunter
sorry joe biden was asked about it on
the campaign trail
but biden's primary opponents you know
bernie sanders elizabeth warren
nobody brought it up remember in 2016
uh when hillary clinton was running and
bernie sanders was the last man standing
he pointedly said you know i think the
story about the emails
you know is ridiculous i think the
clinton foundation stuff is ridiculous
the argument was for unity i think unity
i understand the appeal to it i think at
that stage
it's a mistake because it prevents you
from
airing issues that need to be aired and
again this is where i think you have to
give
trump credit like trump or not like his
policies or not
in the 2016 primary he was very open
uh you know not only sort of calling out
people on their policies
but calling them out on the fact that
that you know they had deals or that
they were engaged in in behavior that
was corrupt or they were part of the
swamp
to my mind that's a healthy process you
need that kind of a cleansing process
and people are counting on a primary to
be a horse race
but if you have a situation where you
know a number of horses
in the in the race are not running as
hard as as fast
as they could uh in the name of unity it
undermines the process and you end up
getting a
president-elect as i think we have with
joe biden
that is going to be weakened hunter
biden issue is not going to go away
and you have this very real problem
of the fact that the president of the
united states's
son may be subject to extortion
uh or some kind of let's say persuasion
by a foreign power because they have
knowledge about things that he's engaged
in
uh that he does not want to come out
that's a very serious problem
this should have been aged in the it
should have been aired in the primary
but it was not and i think to the
detriment of the country
yeah i i and i don't think anything's uh
in my opinion i don't think anything's
gonna change there
do you think it's a good thing let's
just say let's give an example okay pick
mcconnell pick the senator from missouri
you were talking about
uh pick uh uh uh clinton's pick biden
let's just pick any of the families
whichever one it is do you think it's
good for america
if the law came down
hard public humiliating you know it's
it's out in the front
everybody has to report it you don't
even have a choice to avoid it
whether your name is hannity tucker or
don lemon or cuomo you have to report
what's being said
do you think it would be a good thing
for america if one of these
corrupt families was exposed publicly
yes absolutely no question about it i i
think that
we are a country that's ruled by laws
not by men
uh i'm certainly not a lawyer so i'm not
going to be able to talk about the
specific code but there's no question in
my mind
if laws have been broken uh charges need
to be brought
but i would be even more sharp than that
i think it's the obligation of the media
uh to be calling out powerful elected
officials
and part of the reason that they don't
do it uh is because they want access
you know if you run a particularly harsh
story on mitch mcconnell or on job
you're not going to get access to the
sort of information that you might need
to run your news organization
you have to have a cultural phenomenon i
mean the reason i think particularly the
washington post
the new york times some of these network
uh television programs
don't want to do it is they're part of a
social set
in washington dc they're part of the
establishments
and they don't want to call out somebody
else in the establishment whether it's a
powerful senator
or the president of the united states
for fear that they're going to be
shunned the way you might have been
shunned in middle school
if you did something embarrassing so i
think social pressure is brought to bear
but but the the the old uh muckraking
journalism that we're used to thinking
of
where where it's deep exposition the
finances of our elected officials
of the foreign ties of our elected
officials that
used to be the kinds of stories that we
would expect to say is 60 minutes
in the 1970s or 1980s those days are
gone
um and and we are missing a vigorous
media that is holding our leaders into
account they are absent
uh and that means that we have to have
other institutions we need to have
programs like this
we need to have organizations like mine
uh we need alternative sources of news
media to hold them into account because
if they're not held into account
it's just going to become worse and
worse and worse
let me let me ask you a question where
would you put dick cheney on this on the
uh families corrupt families would you
put them anywhere on the list or no
the only reason i ask is because the
movie that came out a couple of years
ago
vice played by christian bale and
how they sold him being the real master
decision maker behind closed doors
with george w just being a nice guy that
was you know
trying to do his best to be a president
what would you put cheney on that list
well there's always been a question
about cheney uh and his
um you know his corporate ties and his
work uh
in the private sector uh from when he
was set deaf in the bush administration
that when he became
vice president of the united states um
he had certainly a lot of stock options
that were coming as a result of that
um so um there certainly are issues of
conflicts of interest that need to be
raised there
um i don't know uh if those decisions
influenced
um were influenced by those but it's
certainly something that needs to be
investigated and explored
i haven't looked at it i'm looking at
current uh elected officials as it comes
out
but i welcome it i think there should be
scrutiny of all of that
um transparency is a good thing the
american people i believe
are forgiving people and what do i mean
by that they recognize that political
leaders need to make a living
they recognize that people go in and out
of government and in and out of the
private sector
they're sophisticated enough to know
that they also know
when people are enriching based on their
government office so
i would say that that needs to be
investigated um uh
thoroughly fair enough i got a couple
more topics before we wrap up here you
know
we've talked about a lot of different
people politicians billionaires
we've talked about media we've talked
about you know lobbyists we talk a lot
of different people
who would you say in order are the most
powerful people
in america the actual politicians the
billionaires
the media folks the lobbyists or others
i'd say the most power of right now
are the titans of silicon valley uh
because of the stranglehold that they
have on
information uh and we've seen uh uh you
know some evidence of that with twitter
banning the new york post but it goes
far far far deeper than that uh you know
the vast majority of people
some estimate 80 are getting their news
and their information uh basically from
platforms like facebook and twitter
uh that they're relying on google for
their search algorithms
um and and they have an ability to
manipulate news and information and they
use it uh and that to me is extremely
troubling because
they essentially walk in lockstep they
all have generally the same worldview
uh and they can use that power in such a
way as to influence
the politicians and who gets elected so
i would put
silicon valley titans first not just
because of their wealth
but because of their ability to control
information
um i report second upon that uh public
uh
government officials being president of
the united states and members of
congress
um what you often see is
you know whether it's people in wall
street people in
oil companies who are rich who are
successful
going to washington dc with their tail
between the legs and oftentimes they
should but that's a demonstration of the
power and the authority
that government has think about it this
way
bill gates founder of microsoft
enormously wealthy
uh enormously successful does he have
more
power than the number two person
at the environmental protection agency
epa
i would argue he does not think about it
this way
bill gates made his money by selling
computers
voluntary exchange people give money to
microsoft
microsoft sends you the product that
you're buying that's how he made his
money
now he's got money he can fund political
campaigns
he can fund charitable activities but
bill gates
cannot really legally compel anybody to
do
anything and bill gates came to me and
said
you know i think your lawn looks bad i
want you to change your lawn
i can tell bill gates to get lost the
number two in charge of the
environmental protection agency has a
lot of power
vested in his authority uh he can he can
put in process a procedure to confiscate
land from individuals
he can bring criminal charges against
uh individuals that he feels have
violated
um the environment and he may or may not
be right
but the point is who has actually the
power to compel people to do something
i would say they had the number two
person at the epa has more power
than bill gates does so government
officials seconds
um and then i would probably uh list um
third um uh the media uh and what i mean
by that is sort of the main media their
ability
to uh uh influence and determine
what stories and what narratives that
they feel are important
and and where do billionaires rank on
here nowhere i would put 30 years below
that because i would say that
i don't view billionaires as a monolith
um there are certainly ones that are
very engaged in wanting to sort of
transform
uh uh american society i mean george
soros for example
uh very very active in a number of
initiatives
he wants to reshape things in the united
states and other parts of the world
in the way that he wants them to and he
can do that he's rich and he runs these
charities
you can look at somebody on the right
side of the spectrum who's more
libertarian
you look at you can look at the koch
brothers and say that they're doing the
same thing
so there's no question that they have
power and that they have influence
but i think they're less monolithic than
the media they're less monolithic than
silicon valley
um and they certainly uh can make a huge
difference
uh but i think it's much more
constrained and limited and by the way
let me just add one of the reasons that
has changed again i would return to
uh the election of donald trump donald
trump in 2016
shattered what was considered an iron
rule of politics for decades which was
the guy who raises the most money the
guy who gets the most
big money donors from wall street and
everywhere else
is elected president of the united
states donald trump did not do that in
he broke that rule and i think it's a
great thing that he did
and i think it's one of the reasons that
billionaires don't have the power that
they did
maybe eight or ten years ago where would
you put universities on there would
universities be below billionaires and
media and government officials
yeah if you think long term in terms of
long-term power
uh you probably have to put them up at
number one or number two
uh because again their ability to shape
uh the viewing
attitudes of people um and and it is
stunning
uh the the fact that the uh first
amendment that freedom of thought
is being diminished on our universities
is is outrageous
it also speaks to me though to this it
speaks to me
the complete lack of confidence that the
hard left in this country
actually has because if the hard left
believed that their ideas were
attractive that their ideas were
seductive that their ideas
were superior to those being presented
by conservatives or moderates
they would want an open discussion they
would want to expose
the weakness uh the the fallibility the
ridiculousness
of conservative ideas but they don't do
that
because they recognize that their ideas
really are not that attractive
the only way that they can get the
adoption of their ideas
is by creating an environment where
other ideas are excluded
so that gives them enormous power but
they're also in my mind a paper tiger
uh and when you get a competition of
ideas they are generally going to lose
powerful so number one it could be a
1a1b
tightness of silicon valley university
so university is more long-term social
media right now
number two or number three would be
government government officials
president congress senate next or would
you say president congress governor how
would you
how would you put that listen president
congress so much of the power now is in
washington d.c
it shouldn't be but it is it is what it
is then we have media mainstream media
then it's billionaires
billionaires don't have as much
influence as it used to have which is
actually very good news to see that
taking place
um this this next topic we'll go into
it's either going to be a 30-second
topic or it could be a five-minute topic
voter fraud it's a topic that's coming
up right now obviously as you and i are
talking about this
president trump is probably tweeting
saying we're gonna win we got this they
did this they did voter fraud
and you got the other side to say listen
just concede already give it up
already you know let's move on already
and then you're saying constitutional
attorneys saying
look he's not going to concede he's
going to drag this out and if he gets
into a supreme court
and he won kavanaugh and he won you know
amy coney barrett what most people don't
realize is back in 2000
when george bush and gore were going
through it both kavanaugh and coney bear
were part of that when they took place
and it flipped obviously who became
president for 30 days
al gore was a president-elect how much
value are you putting behind what
giuliani what a lot of these guys are
doing right now in trump's camp
with voter fraud well i think voter
fraud
is a huge problem we've actually done
research on that at the government
accountability institute
it's a huge problem the reason it's a
huge problem
is not only because it happens and it's
increasingly happening
it's it's it's very very difficult to
detect
and this is the problem so you know
inevitably
there are going to be lots of examples
that have brought forward of
dead people voting of people saying that
a ballot was cast in their name when
they didn't vote
or somebody that was denied to vote
because it was said that they had
already voted you're going to find
lots of examples of that the challenge
and the problem
is showing critical mass and the size
and the scope of how much voter fraud
has happened
i don't know the answer that i don't
think anybody does i think absolutely
uh it's good and it's healthy uh for
president trump
to go through this process uh he has
every right to
um and look washington dc and and our
system of government is a
is a government of institutions we have
courts we have laws we have a process
that can be followed
and claims a voter fraud and going
through judicial review are part of that
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with doing that and i think you should
be doing that
the question will come down i think
ultimately to the supreme court
um i'm not an expert on the supreme
court i i
i fear uh that uh chief justice roberts
and others
are going to be loaded to be sort of
thrust into the middle of this
for fear of of the damage in their mind
that it might do
to the supreme court my view is this is
precisely the sort of the thing
that the supreme court should evaluate
and should look into
assuming that these uh suits that have
been introduced
have claims there's merit to them which
i think there probably is
um so i think the process should go
forward but a lot of people that
sort of are embracing the notion of the
sky is following what are we going to do
we went through this in 2000 we're going
to go through this now
it's not going to be a process that a
large portion of people are going to be
happy with
at the end of the day but this is the
nature of the american system
and those that are saying he shouldn't
do this this is un-american this is
wrong
uh i think they're being ridiculous and
and have a very short memory
uh particularly when after 2016 so many
people
uh like hillary clinton others were
saying that he was not the legitimate
president
i think if joe biden survives these
court challenges and the votes stay in
place
joe biden is the president of the united
states but donald trump
has certainly a legitimate reason to
challenge
some of the voting in some of these
states through the judicial process
sure enough i think it's fair to say
that joe biden and
trump are very different types of
presidents and candidates so let's
assume
he goes through inauguration trump
concedes it's done joe biden's the
president 46 it's official everybody
knows about it
what does a vitamin administration look
like the next two to four years
i think it's going to be a
administration that on foreign policy
will be center
left uh and then when it comes to
secretary of labor labor policy treasury
departments
uh will be much more progressive into
the left to the hard left
and they will try to use their executive
authority
um to um advance their agenda um i do
think that the republicans will hold the
senate um and that they will
successfully block a lot of the more
radical initiatives that are being
pushed
and i go from the house of
representatives nancy pelosi has
certainly had her wings clipped
uh her majority has shrunk uh and a lot
of people that are in
swing districts uh that are democrats
are not going to want to
follow a lot of the more radical agenda
but let me
you know let's be clear there's a lot of
damage that can be done
by bernie sanders as a secretary of
labor by elizabeth warren
as uh secretary of the treasury there's
a lot that can be done
to damage the energy industry uh through
regulation
um so uh the damage will be done
but it will be obviously more limited uh
because of the restrictions imposed by a
republican senate
so it's gonna be bad but not as bad
because they have to win senate for that
to take place which is leading us to
georgia knowing the fact that those two
seats this will be the last topic we'll
cover and we'll wrap up
they're saying 200 million is going to
put into uh uh this runoff that's going
to take place in georgia
where are you at with how this is going
to take place and how it's going to end
up and how ugly it could potentially get
in georgia
well my hope is and this is where my
optimist comes in
my hope is because so much is riding on
this election
it's one state in georgia that
a lot of the funny business that we've
seen a lot of other states about
back dating uh ballots about
signing as a witness when a witness was
required that a lot of that would be a
lot
harder to pull off in a systematic way
given the focus in georgia
and that's incumbent upon the republican
party uh
and and journalists to look at this
stuff seriously to follow it
i think it would be a fair process i
think at the end of the day
um and i'm not terribly great at
predictions so there's not a lot of
value in this
i think at the end of the day uh the
republicans will probably carry these
seats
uh because i think georgia remains a a
center-right state
i think in the presidential race you
have questions about certain ballots i
also think you saw in suburban atlanta
a lot of people who are let's say
center-right
um who for personal reasons uh because
of his manners because of his tweetings
we're not voting for donald trump but i
do think we'll turn around
and vote for republican senate so you
think it's essentially going to end up
being 52 to 48 when the whole thing is
over with
yes that's that's my prediction on
terrible permissions i will go on the
record and say
romney was gonna win and in 2016 i
thought hillary clinton was going to win
so
i'm not a great man for predictions but
that's what i think is going to happen
in georgia
well first of all class act i've really
enjoyed talking to you the last
you know 80 minutes or so 90 minutes or
so thank you for your insight folks if
you're watching this
uh we're gonna put the link below to all
three of his books with the one at the
top being profiles and corruption
for you to be able to order for yourself
i suggest you order all three of them
well again put the link below
uh on the three books that he has and
with that being said peter thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
thank you i enjoyed it very much thank
you so what do you think about what
peter schweitzer said do you think
there's a lot of corruption in politics
in america
yes no maybe and if yes who
how and what can be done about it
comment below and if you enjoyed this
interview i have another interview to
watch that's similar to this from
the author of economic hitman his story
if you've never
heard his story probably one of the most
unique stories of what john perkins did
click over here to watch that interview
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care
you